[Applause]
that's my jam with miss over here oh my
god well i was like we're competitive
yeah so i love that i'm very competitive
well i'm see i kind of am i competitive
oh no yeah the person that yeah
is totally competitive
screaming at game nights and stuff i
mean she's the one who's like i'm like
it's a it's a game night we're supposed
to have a good shut up i know
he so all of her accusations of cheating
all the time after
after the jimmy fallon thing i literally
called all i'm like was i nuts like was
i did i come across like too competitive
this is exactly what i asked about my
friends about me when i was on the show
i was like yeah because like
yeah because like because something
happens yeah me too and you're i'm just
like i'm just like get me
get me in it yeah you know and it's like
it takes you over completely yes
but why play unless you're going to
compete that's what i say i'm like
you know look at him
you show up to win not
i really do because
because she's like okay because you're
not competitive enough no no no okay no
it's because i have i have fear
when i'm going up against like leo
dicaprio and tom hanks and you know and
oliver and like you know that's
ridiculous no it's true like sir anthony
hopkins is doing like running charades
i would never want to play charades in
that comic
anything for sir anthony hopkins to do
no but i'm not i i'm serious in that
like i have anxiety for game night
because she invites very prominent
people who are professionals
academy awards here's the thing here's
here's what the truth is that i used to
invite him and he never showed up
so then i just stopped inviting him yeah
because he'd never well first of all
your wife is always so late i know that
the party would be like done
i know it's true erin you're like it's
the kid's birthday it's 5 30. and like
literally it's like 8 p.m i'm like erin
are you where are the kids she's like no
no we're in the car we're in the car
those are people that's the thing like
some people don't do well with time
management what no i know i'm not late
for a game night and i'm not late for a
game no no i'm not late for like a gig
no i'm never those people that wait i
don't know why fans do that like three
hours later the artist gets on stage i'm
like terrible i'm at like waffle house
by then like i'm like
i'm like gone by then no i i i now i
want to have a game night with you oh my
you i don't know if you don't have to do
it
i get it i get crazy here's the thing
i'm not a sore loser that's not i don't
care if i lose but i don't want to play
with people that don't want to play yeah
get out of here i can't stand i i get
that of course and then they make you
feel bad that you're competitive yeah
but when it's sweet but when it's like
christmas eve and we're playing game
night with the family and all of a
sudden everyone's screaming at each
other like you cheated
of course mom has left the room 30
minutes ago she's like i'm not dealing
with any of this and she's gone you can
see mom's face when we all decide to
play a game it's like
that's my mother yeah it's like no my
mother cannot stand because me and my
sister like we we don't play with
cheaters either yeah you are kicked out
we actually my sister and i on tour we
didn't allow dennis our tour manager to
play yahtzee with us again because he
cheats no because he didn't get excited
about his freaking yahtzee oh he did it
he got a yahtzee and he just was like he
literally went oh nazi and i was like no
no
you're banned right you're banned from
that the word is designed for you to
scream
what's like your game of choice well
game night is usually mafia do you know
mafia no it's like woo
wait it's like werewolves
are dead at the end
well pretty much
pretty much uh except tom hanks yeah he
always wins tom hanks nobody wants to
game tom hanks no you're right this is
weird
i'm not kidding no no it's like
so here so
mafia okay is a game that was actually
there's a it's the english version is
called werewolves and villagers and it
was apparently i could be totally wrong
created by the mi6 to see how
sociopathic you are at live right it's
basically like if you're if you can
convince somebody and lie that well then
you're on like a good path to being a
spy you know wow but you play with a lot
of actors this must be hard i wasn't
really [ __ ] you were like no i would
comment
seriously and all of a sudden leo is
looking at music
if you ever invite me i'm terrified of
that like around actors oh it's so much
fun it really is so much fun and and um
the thing the only i would never do it
with a partner i think it's broken up
most of my partnerships
[Laughter]
i how did you kill me
i can't believe you just killed me i am
you you're playing a game yeah and then
you know you're in a game it's like if
they're doing something wrong and even
if you're on the same team and you know
you have to kill them you're like i got
to kill my i got to kill him oh yeah and
and it's over it's like it really gets
personal that's happened a couple times
at game night okay yeah like people have
left early yeah
i don't do well with subjective games
and crowds like with we're playing games
with subjective
i know it would happen it would just all
of a sudden like halfway through you'd
be like i know you're mine yeah like
wait here's the here's the here's a good
example of how i play games so i did
hollywood game night and isla fisher was
on my team and this is how crazy i get
she literally being a girls girl like
leaned over me and she was like hey just
let you know like maybe you want to like
not drink anymore and i was like oh i
i
i was like fake drinking i was like not
really drinking and i was like oh
this is just like who i am i was like
this is not
this is not alcohol we won't we're not
friends i was like i was like she thinks
i'm too much i am but i like playing
games anyway enough about me and my
craziness
[Music]
you